CBS News has learned most of Puerto Rico
could get power back on today after the
island strongest earthquake in more than
a century in the southwest in the
southwestern part of the island the
quake knocked some homes right off their
foundations this is what it looks like
now in the city of Jaco were more than a
thousand people slept at an outdoor
shelter near a local Stadium last night
our lead national correspondent David
Beck know was there David good morning
to you I know the gentlemen at the power
plant told you they're working 24/7 we
didn't see anybody working so I was
wondering how do they get it on so
quickly why are they so confident they
can do this well Gail they got
generation from a private plant and
another one from a government-owned
plant enough to generate the electricity
they need to give power back to 80
percent of the customers here and let me
tell you something
social media is lighting up this morning
with folks saying powers back on and my
waters back on but just as soon as it
comes on it goes off it's unreliable but
that's one of the realities of living
here in Puerto Rico the fact that the
earthquakes are still happening
is why these folks slept outside yet
again feeling safer on a cot under a
tent than in their own homes listen this
morning I want to take you into the
beautiful mountains of Jellico where
some families are living in their front
yard doing the best that they can last
night was the third night the Gomez
family slept outside in a tent they
don't have power or running water I
tried to call my my kids but it's very
difficult mom Jenny says she can't stop
worrying about another aftershock she
and her husband Jose prepare to live
outdoors indefinitely
we got doubts about sending our kids
back to a school right because where my
kids study is a 100 year building and
[Music]
it's uh it's gonna be tough to get back
to the normal life after all the chicks
we met the mayor of Jellico on Hill
Torres at a meeting he had with island
officials and FEMA earlier in the day he
walked out of that mightier frustrated
I'm not feeling good at all I have to go
back to my town to see that face of my
people and try to help them and we need
the help from the government
we livestream that interview on social
media and I told the mayor we check back
in with him later
meanwhile we were getting messages from
people saying go to the nearby
municipality of pendulous there are
people in need there so we did and we
met the mayor Gregory Gonzalez I just
want to send a message to our nation
- Oh PO ricans here in Pinellas we need
a lot of water based on that I reached
out to the central government to find
out why water had not been set they told
us it was on the way and we later got
these photos showing water being loaded
into trucks headed for pinwheels we left
there and headed to Joko to check back
in with Mayor Torres when we showed up
he was smiling the FEMA people came here
just like an hour ago
okay they say that they will give us in
the few in a few hours okay some some
pillows on blanket and some couches you
see like
and that we need before we go we want
you to see this Immaculate Conception
Church in Gua Nia
we went there Wednesday built in 1841 it
was destroyed by Tuesday 6.4 magnitude
quake it's worth noticing what appears
to be untouched the statues have fallen
the altars there the side walls to both
collapsed but the gospel book untouched
and on the wall there you see the crack
in it but the picture of Christ appears
to be untouched and sitting on a Pew the
baby Jesus the church pastor told this
young man Luis to take it to his mother
and ask her to care for it until the
church is rebuilt when he placed it in
his mother's arms she cradled it like it
was her own child and wept the members
of the community who were there and saw
that were silent as they watched since
December 28 there had been more than
2,000 earthquakes to hit Puerto Rico 60
of those were actually felt and Gael
three of them happened just today so
there's things encouraging there thank
you very much David Beck now reporting
from Puerto Rico that scenes from the
church is very touching yeah book is
open the picture of Jesus is okay it's
they have a long road back we cover
hurricanes and earthquakes in Puerto
Rico it's worth remembering it's also a
gorgeous place to live so many people
were there
you